einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zu heute live heute mit der
frage und dem thema bringt der
jahreswechsel die wende in sachen corona
pandemie wir hoffen alle natürlich
darauf aber wir diskutieren die frage
wird dem auch so sein und ihr könnt
natürlich herzlich mitmachen herzlich
gerne das ganze zum beispiel mit hilfe
der unten eingeblendeten adresse jetzt
aber zunächst zu unserem gast wir
sprechen über dieses thema heute abend
mit frau professor ulrike protzer von
der technischen universität in münchen
virologin guten abend frau professor
[Musik]
guten abend wunderbar elias wechsel
steht bevor und viele menschen werden ja
nicht besonders gerne auf das
abgelaufene jahr zurück blicken mit
welchen gefühlen schauen sie hier auf
2020 zurück auch gemischt natürlich es
war sehr aufregend das war aber auch
sehr stressig es war ein up und down der
gefühle schon sehr gemischt wir wollen
uns jetzt auch in unserem live stream
hauptsächlich mit der aktualität und
dann auch mit einem ausblick
beschäftigen auf die kommenden wochen
und monate aber vielleicht noch mal ganz
kurz zu beginn der rückblick gab es
dinge jetzt in 2020 die aus ihrer sicht
besonders gut gelaufen sind im umgang
mit der pandemie oder auch solche die
besonders schlecht gehandelt wurden
ich glaube ganz am anfang waren wir
wirklich sehr gut weil wir einfach sehr
sehr schnell reagiert haben
wir hatten natürlich den vorteil muss
man auch ehrlich sagen wir haben gesehen
was in italien passiert wir haben das
ganze auf uns zurollen sehen und wir
hatten durch dieses webasto cluster was
hier war ja schon uns angefangen im
januar schon mit dem ganzen thema zu
beschäftigen und das hat uns erlaubt das
doch sehr schnell und sehr gut in den
griff zu bekommen
dann kommt natürlich das problem wenn
man ja prophylaktisch handelt präventiv
handelt und ist erfolgreich dann sagen
alle ja da ist aber doch gar nichts
und das war das was vielleicht nicht so
gut gelaufen ist es ist uns mich oder
nicht ausreichend gelungen die
aufmerksamkeit auch und die die leute
dann genügend bei der stange zu halten
und dann wirklich jetzt im herbst diese
zweite welle zumindest zu reduzieren
ganz verhindern hätte man sich
wahrscheinlich gar nicht können schauen
wir noch mal auf die gegenwart frau
professor wir sprechen natürlich gleich
weiter aber der gesundheitsministerien
sparen hat heute nochmal flankiert von
zwei experten die hoffnung geschürt auch
vor allem die hoffnung dahin gehend dass
es eben schon bald viel mehr impfstoff
geben werde der uns allen zur verfügung
steht bis dahin so der minister sei eben
noch geduld gefragt
ein minister zwei wissenschaftler
es ist die letzte pressekonferenz dieser
art in pandemie jahr 2020 die kritik an
jens spahn es gebe zu wenig impfstoff
die impfungen verliebten zu langsam
sparen bittet um geduld man müsse
wertschätzen dass es überhaupt so
schnell an impfstoff gebe und die harten
zeiten sie sei noch nicht vorbei im
gegenteil 1129 todesfälle sind allein an
diesem morgen zu beklagen 1129 familien
werden diesen jahreswechsel in trauer
erleben also wohl keine lockerung nach
dem zehnten januar
doch wie erklären sich die höchsten
todeszahlen seit beginn der pandemie
selbst der chef des robert
koch-instituts muss spekulieren
die plausibelste erklärung wäre dass es
verzögerte meldung
sind impfung sei der einzige weg aus der
pandemie das paul ehrlich institut
zuständig für impfstoffe versichert
kurzfristige und langfristige
überwachung
wir bieten eine app an
diese app kann benötigt werden von den
personen die geimpft werden
jens spahn erwartet für die nächste
woche die zulassung eines impfstoffs des
us-konzerns moderner der britische
impfstoff von astra weniger wurde heute
in großbritannien zugelassen und könnte
bald in der eu zur verfügung stehen das
ziel des ministeriums so schnell so viel
impfstoff wie möglich es ist ein rennen
gegen die zeit
wir schauen gleich auf die verschiedenen
impfstoffe frau professor prozession ist
aber die frage nach den hohen
todeszahlen von heute gab es gerade auf
der pressekonferenz gehört also weit
über 1000 das treibt natürlich viele
menschen um
wie sieht ihre erklärung dafür aus hat
das statistische gründe oder ist das
tatsächlich noch eine nachlässigkeit von
uns allen im umgang mit dem virus das
ist eine frage die übrigens auch george
google-account an uns richtet warum sind
die todeszahlen derzeit zu extrem hoch
ich glaube nicht dass das sein
statistisches problem ist denn wenn
jemand stirbt das ist ja doch sehr
eindeutig da brauche ich jetzt nicht
wahnsinnig viel statistik dafür das
problem ist dass die todeszahlen immer
das reflektieren was vor drei wochen
passiert ist weil man an dieser
erkrankung ja nicht sofort stirbt
sondern man wird erst schwerer krank man
muss ins krankenhaus und erst in der
nachfolge stirbt man daran dass das
hinkt hinterher
und damit ist es natürlich schon
irgendwo unsere nachlässigkeit von vor
drei wochen
was folgt für sie daraus was muss anders
werden jetzt auch unmittelbar
gegenwärtig für unseren umgang mit der
pandemie gut gegenwärtig haben wir jetzt
sehr starke einschränkungen
wir haben die schulen geschlossen wir
haben alle in sommerfest geschickt wir
haben einen weitestgehenden lockdown
auch in den geschäften
da es nicht mehr so wahnsinnig viel
spielraum drin außer man sagt jetzt ok
jeder bleibt zu hause und geht nur noch
einen kilometer außerhalb des eigenen
hauses was wir sehen ist ja schon dass
die zahlen zumindest die zahlen sind
rückgängig das heißt auf jeden fall
haben wir diesen anstieg den wir vor
weihnachten hatten ausgebremst keine
frage was einen noch so ein bisschen
skeptisch lässt und da muss man
tatsächlich die nächsten paar tage
abwarten ist wie viel ist jetzt
realistisch an dem abfall der zahlen
denn was wir leider auch sehen ist dass
die quote der positiven teste im moment
immer noch sehr hoch ist das lässt ein
bisschen vermuten dass wir die zahlen
unterschätzen und einfach weniger
getestet und vielleicht auch weniger
gemeldet wird und wir nicht ganz
realistisch sind mit dem was er jetzt
heute an sinkenden zahlen gehört haben
das heißt wir müssen also weiter
aufmerksam beobachten wie sich die
zahlen entwickeln
hoffnung macht auf jeden fall der beginn
der impfkampagne es ist die größte in
der geschichte der bundesrepublik in
großbritannien das sollte noch ein
weiterer impfstoff zugelassen worden der
von astrazeneca werden sven auch im
beitrag gehört das wird in europa noch
ein bisschen dauern in kontinentaleuropa
bis er dort auch zugelassen werden wird
es gibt unterschiedliche impfstoffe und
wie diese verschiedenen impfstoffe
wirken
dazu jetzt noch mal ein paar
einzelheiten von meinem kollegen heiko
kunzmann
die derzeit verfügbaren impfstoffe
funktionieren nach zwei wirkungsweisen
der klassische weg hier basiert der
impfstoff auf abgeschwächten viren die
sollen die abwehr des menschlichen
körpers ankurbeln
dazu zählt das präparat des britisch
schwedischen konzerns astrazeneca wie
wirksam es schützt hängt von der
dosierung ab bei studien waren etwa 70
prozent der teilnehmer am ende immun
vorteile des astra zeneca stoffes er ist
preiswert und kann unkompliziert
gelagert werden bei kühlschrank
temperaturen ist er sechs monate haltbar
das zweite wirkprinzip sind sogenannte m
rna impfstoffe die präparate von beyond
advisor und moderner
hier werden genetische informationen des
corona virus geimpft quasi ein bauplan
der körper stellt damit selbst virus
proteine her und gegen die bildet das
immunsystem dann abwehrstoffe das
impfmittel von bayern takt pfizer hat
laut studien eine wirksamkeit von über
90 prozent
es kostet jedoch mehr als das mittel von
astrazeneca und muss aufwändig bei minus
70 grad gelagert werden
das präparat des us-herstellers moderner
erreicht eine schutzwirkung ebenfalls
von über 90 prozent
es kann 30 tage bei kühlschrank
temperaturen gelagert werden ist jedoch
der teuerste der drei impfstoffe
also wir sehen die impfstoffe alle mit
unterschiedlichen eigenschaften und auch
spezifischen vor und nachteilen wie
wichtig ist es aus ihrer sicht dass man
da einen mix an verschiedenen präparaten
ich glaube der mix ist schon wichtig
weil wir natürlich erst mal
unterschiedliche länder bedienen müssen
mich jeder hat so viel geld wie jetzt
deutschland oder auch andere reiche
industriestaaten nicht jeder hat
überhaupt die kapazität das was man an
logistik braucht für diesen boten-rna
impfstoff von moderner oder auch von
bayer entdeckt zur verfügung zu stellen
das heißt man braucht ganz sicher um
weltweit impfen zu können und das müssen
wir um fair zu sein
verschiedene präparate im privatfunk
schreibt uns über youtube kann der
impfstoff die situation wirklich
entschärfen oder auch endlich drastisch
verbessern meine frage ist sehr ernst
gemeint
da ich mich auf jeden fall impfen lasse
aber es bleibt ein ungutes gefühl zurück
warum schreibt er nicht also bis der
impfstoff wirklich die situation
komplett kontrollieren kann brauchen wir
eine so genannte herdenimmunität und die
herdenimmunität setzt sich aus zwei
teilen zusammen das eine ist die
immunität die da ist wollen jemand sich
schon infiziert hatte und das andere ist
die immunität die man mit dem impfstoff
erzeugt und beides zusammen muss bei
einem virus mit dem es hier zu tun haben
was ja nicht hochinfektiös aber doch
eine ordentliche infektiosität hat etwa
65 prozent betragen
man muss also die 65 prozent der
bevölkerung müssen immun seien damit
dieses virus sich nicht mehr weiter
ausbreiten kann
und das muss man sich überlegen wie
erreicht man dass man sagt okay jahr
zwei bis drei prozent haben die
infektion durchgemacht vielleicht sind
am ende der saison sogar fünf prozent
dann heißt es ich muss noch 60 prozent
impfen damit im nächsten herbst nicht
wieder das gleiche passiert und das ist
natürlich schon eine menge holz 60
prozent der bevölkerung ist viel
aber ich muss ja nicht unbedingt eine
komplette herdenimmunität erzeugen wenn
ich schon mal diejenigen schützen kann
und das kann ja wirklich dieser
impfstoff nun sehr sehr gut die krank
werden können
da ist ja schon der erste wirklich große
schritt gemacht und deswegen hat man
sich auch auf die im freien folge so
geeinigt dass man sagt okay lasst uns
doch erstmal die schützen die wirklich
gefährdet sind und die das brauchen
bevor man dann sagt jetzt versucht man
wirklich dieses virus möglichst komplett
einzudämmen
ja das wird ja jedenfalls noch monate
dauern bis dann alle an der reihe sind
relativ viele leute stellen diese frage
für die junge leute auch sollte man sich
impfen lassen wenn man bereits corona
hatte das ist eine sehr gute frage
die studien und da beziehe ich mich
jetzt wieder auf diese boten rna
impfstoffe die übrigens keine
genetischen impfstoffe sind das waren
ihren beitrag mich so ganz korrekt das
ist ein botenstoff der zelle diese rna
von der eiweiß gebildet wird und keine
genetische information ich glaube das
ist ganz wichtig auch wieder anders zu
verstehen
[Musik]
aber wenn ich jetzt müssen wir die frage
da noch mal sagen kommt nicht ob es denn
sinnvoll ist kein problem ob es denn
sinnvoll ist sich impfen zu lassen
nachdem man die krankheit schon
durchgemacht hat
genau dies ist so dass die studien die
bisher gemacht sind ihren endpunkt bei
denjenigen haben die die erkrankung noch
nicht durchgemacht haben die also bisher
keinen schutz haben
in dem zweiten endpunkt und dafür laufen
diese studien auch noch weiter soll
getestet werden ob es auch etwas bringt
wenn man diese erkrankung schon
durchgemacht hat als wenn man schon
infiziert war deshalb im moment ist die
priorität definitiv auf denen die noch
keinen eigenen immunschutz haben also
die die erkrankung nicht durchgemacht
haben oder die infektion nicht
durchgemacht haben muss ja nicht
unbedingt krank werden und erst in einem
zweiten schritt wenn man dann sieht okay
der immunschutz des körpers reicht nicht
mehr aus vielleicht bis zum nächsten
herbst weil die antikörper schon zu
schnell abfallen dann könnte man
überlegen ob man die auch diejenigen mit
impft die das ganze schon gehabt haben
oder jemand hat ein sehr hohes risiko
weil er auf der intensivstation arbeitet
am krankenbett steht und man sagt okay
jetzt braucht jetzt aber einen ganz
sicheren schutz und die eigene immunität
ist vielleicht nicht mehr so gut nach
der durchgemachten infektion das wären
so situationen aber primär erstmal die
priorität auf diejenigen die das noch
nicht gehabt haben ein thema das auch
immer wieder aufkommt und auch fragen
dazu die uns gestellt werden lauten nach
den nebenwirkungen auch vielleicht im
hinblick darauf dass das verfahren zur
herstellung jetzt dieses impfstoffs ja
ungewöhnlich schnell ging was es ihm
dazu bekannt kann man da die ängste
nehmen
also die nebenwirkungen die aufgetreten
sind in diesen beiden großen studien von
moderner von brenntag auch erst 13 egger
also auch dieser dino vector impfstoff
diesen inzwischen in den studien
eigentlich gut beschrieben und
publiziert was man sieht ist auf jeden
fall eine sogenannte reaktor genäht das
kennt man vielleicht vom vom influenza
impfstoff oder weil sie schon mal gegen
fsme oder so hat impfen lassen man merkt
es danach man merkt dass das immunsystem
anspricht das merkt man sowohl an der
einstichstelle wo es dann doch zu einem
druck kommen kann vielleicht zum ziehen
denn gefühl im muskel man merkt es aber
auch in dem man sich insgesamt einfach
wie bei so einer beginnenden erkältung
schlapp fühlt man kann kopfschmerzen
bekommen man kann auch mal ja so ein
kleiner schüttelfrost bekommen
vielleicht auch temperaturen bis 38 5
aber das ist ganz transient wenn man
sich da die daten anschaut dann tritt
das mit einem pkw mit einem jahr spitze
am zweiten tag nach impfung auf und am
dritten tag ist es eigentlich schon
wieder weg und wenn man das weiß dass
man das auch ganz gut beherrschen kann
indem man zum beispiel ja wie man es bei
einer beginnen erkältung auch macht
paracetamol nimmt dann kann man damit
eigentlich gut umgehen richtige
nebenwirkungen also schwerere
nebenwirkungen sind in den studien nicht
aufgetreten und das ist ja schon mal
dass das allerwichtigste das heißt da
scheint eine hohe sicherheit zu bestehen
und jetzt sind ja nicht nur die
studiendaten da sondern es sind ja auch
schon viele tausend menschen nicht nur
in deutschland aber in england den usa
geimpft worden um noch da bisher keine
schweren nebenwirkungen ja und das wird
ja auch weiter beobachtet ein thema was
auch immer wieder bei uns aufkommt ist
die frage nach der mutation aus
großbritannien die ja doch auch für
große nachdenklichkeit sorgt inzwischen
ist sie in mehreren ländern auch in
deutschland nachgewiesen worden wie
gefährlich ist diese mutation das fragt
auch carsten stäcker über youtube kann
der impfstoff auch zum beispiel dagegen
schützen
es ist genau diese mutation nur bedingt
getestet worden nur in kleinen serien da
sieht es so aus als ob es einen
ausreichenden schutz gibt es sind
bestimmt 20 andere mutationen schon sehr
gründlich untersucht worden vor denen es
auf jeden fall geschützt und ich hatte
gerade heute die chance mit einem
kollegen aus london zu sprechen
und der sagte auch die daten sind noch
ein bisschen dünn aber es sieht schon so
aus als ob diese variante ansteckender
ist und zwar nicht so sehr bei diesen
sogenannten super sprayer events die wir
ja bisher auch schon hatten zuviel
übertragung ja in bars oder im auf
veranstaltungen passiert sind wo viele
menschen sind sondern bei der
übertragung innerhalb der familie da war
es ja bisher so dass die gar nicht so
100 prozent war sondern nur selbst von
den familienmitgliedern sich etwa nur 20
25% angesteckt haben und das scheint mit
der neuen variante doch mir zu sein so
zumindest die ersten erkenntnisse in
london eine frage die uns erreicht von
legastheniker über youtube ist es
sinnvoll derzeit einen stoff aus
russland zu beziehen können sie dazu
wasser
ich würde das nicht machen es gibt einen
den oralen vector impfstoff ganz ähnlich
wie der von astrazeneca mit der
university of oxford entwickelt wurde
auch in russland und das ging ja durch
die schlagzeilen dass herr putin seine
tochter gekämpft hat mit diesem sputnik
5 im stoff man muss aber sagen der ist
nicht durch sicherheitsstudien gelaufen
wie sie einfach unseren kriterien
entsprechen
wir sind ja doch sehr sehr strikt mit
allem was sicherheit betrifft und ich
glaube das ist auch gut so und diese
ganzen impfstoffe die jetzt zugelassen
sind die haben diese hohe sicherheits
hürde überwunden für den sputnik fünf
impfstoff der aus russland kommt der
mark und sein aber der ist einfach nicht
so genau geprüft deswegen würde ich ihn
nicht kaufen
eine häufig gestellte frage bei uns ist
auch wie lange hält die schutzwirkung an
nach einer impfung gibt es dazu schon
erkenntnisse
es gibt erste daten dazu
aber die sind natürlich dadurch dass die
impfstudien ja auch noch nicht so
wahnsinnig lange her sind sind auch
diese daten noch nicht so langfristig
man weiß dass es mindestens vier monate
einen guten impfschutz gibt und der
scheint auch ziemlich stabil zu sein und
sogar bessere täter von den antikörpern
die uns also schützen zu machen als nach
einer natürlichen infektion
aber wie lange das dann wirklich anhält
da müssen wir jetzt einfach mal abwarten
denn wenn es den impfstoff noch kein
jahr gibt kann man natürlich auch nicht
sagen der immunschutz das machen ja noch
genauso gut habe ich eigentlich eine
wahl beim impfstoff kann ich sagen ich
möchte mit diesem oder mit jenem
präparat geimpft werden oder wer
entscheidet das überhaupt
prinzipiell habe ich natürlich zum einen
die wahl will ich geimpft werden oder
nicht das ist ja eine freie entscheidung
und wenn verschiedene impfstoffe
verfügbar sind dann habe ich auch die
wahl welchen im stoff ich nehmen möchte
im moment ist wahrscheinlich so ein
bisschen die frage welcher ist denn
überhaupt verfügbar
wir in deutschland haben jetzt sehr gute
verfügbarkeit von den bivalenten
impfstoff und ich persönlich muss sagen
ich lasse mich auch mit dem empfindlich
findet den wirklich sehr gut
eine frage die mich persönlich auch noch
umtreibt ist die frage nach den
medikamenten wir haben viel über die
impfungen gesprochen über das pro und
contra beziehungsweise darüber dass es
natürlich in den augen der meisten ihrer
kollegen sinnvoll ist sich impfen zu
lassen aber was ist eigentlich mit der
medikamentenforschung auf welchem stand
ist die wissenschaft da nicht ganz so
weit ich meine die entwicklung dieses
impfstoffs muss man schon sagen war
wirklich eine unglaubliche
errungenschaft der wissenschaft und die
zusammenarbeit viele wissenschaftler
auch mit biotech firmen und
pharmazeutischen unternehmen ansonsten
wäre so etwas in der geschwindigkeiten
auch in der qualität einfach gar nicht
möglich gewesen
das muss man einfach den kollegen die da
beteiligt waren wirklich neidlos
zugestehen
die medikamentenentwicklung ging nicht
ganz so schnell voran ist auch nicht mit
ganz so viel enthusiasmus und vielleicht
gemeinsamen aktivitäten betrieben worden
aber auch da gibt es eine ganze reihe
präparate die jetzt ganz spezifisch für
corona viren oder sogar für dieses virus
entwickelt wurden und das braucht man
auch das macht auch absolut sinn denn
nur den impfstoff zu haben wird ja immer
noch bedeuten dass ein paar menschen
trotzdem sich infizieren können
denn bis die ganze welt mal wirklich
durchkämpft ist das wird einfach sehr
sehr lange dauern und dann braucht man
natürlich medikamente für diejenigen die
schwer
und die im krankenhaus liegen und die
die wir bisher haben die sind einfach
leider limitiert deswegen ist es ganz
ganz wichtig dass wir da auch die
forschung weiter vorantreiben
das ist auch erkannt worden und es gibt
jetzt auch neue förderprogramme sowohl
für kleine innovative firmen als auch
für die akademische forschung um das
wirklich noch mal intensiver zu tun
frau professor an dieser stelle schon
mal vielen dank dass ihr uns zur
verfügung stehen wir bekommen unheimlich
viele zuschriften gerade über die
sozialen netzwerke rhein ganz toll dass
sie sich die zeit nehmen und da das ein
oder andere auch für uns beantworten
sie schreibt er möchte wissen wie der
erfolg der impfung überprüft werden kann
also wie funktioniert das ist das dann
einfach nur das ergebnis das ich
sozusagen die krankheit nicht bekomme
oder woher weiß ich dass es daran lag
also was man macht in so großen
zulassungsstudien und das ist auch in
den studien für die ganzen impfstoffe
gemacht worden
man macht eine doppelblindstudie dh man
impft einmal mit einem placebo einem
nicht wirksamen impfstoff an einmal mit
einem wirksamen impfstoff und leder
derjenige der immer noch derjenige der
dem stoff bekommt weiß was er bekommen
hat und dann verfolgt man die personen
nach und dann sieht man erzählt man wie
viel haben sie sich denn in welcher
gruppe infiziert und wenn man sich jetzt
da zum beispiel wieder die daten von den
brenntag an impfstoff anguckt die dann
zur zulassung geführt haben dann waren
das in der gruppe die das placebo also
dem nicht wirksamen stoffe erhalten
haben 162 und das waren in der gruppe
die den wirksamen impfstoff entwickelt
haben bekommen haben acht und wenn man
das gegeneinander rechnet dann sagt man
eben es sind 95% wirksamkeit nicht 100
prozent weil sich ja eben macht auch von
den 20.000 menschen angesteckt haben die
geimpft wurden aber natürlich deutlich
mehr mit 162 von denen die eben nicht
wirksam kämpft wurden
ich möchte hier noch ein bisschen mit
ihnen auch auf die nächsten wochen
schauen vielleicht sogar auf die
nächsten monate
am dienstag am fünften januar kommt die
politik zu erneuten beratungen zusammen
und da wird es darum gehen ob der locker
und der schotter und nach dem 10
januar aufgehoben werden kann was kann
denn bei diesen beratungen aus ihrer
sicht anderes herauskommen als dass es
noch nicht aufgehoben werden kann
ich befürchte im moment nicht so
wahnsinnig viel denn die zahlen sind
einfach realistisch gesehen noch zu hoch
um sagen zu können okay wir können jetzt
hier wieder lockern
die ministerpräsidenten müssen
sicherlich gemeinsam beraten wie geht
man jetzt dann vor allem auch mit
schulen um wie geht man mit mit
wirtschaftsunternehmen um das sind jetzt
politische entscheidungen die da gefällt
werden müssen aber die kurve muss
sicherlich noch weiter nach unten bevor
man jetzt wieder öffnen kann sonst
passiert das was in amerika passiert ist
dass es dann erstmal richtig hoch
schießt und ich glaube das wollen wir
alle mich wenn man sich die situation im
krankenhaus hier anschaut die knappheit
die wir haben an normal betten an
intensivbetten dass es wirklich eng und
wir haben hier wirklich erhebliche
probleme und ich glaube da müssen wir
einfach erst für eine entspannung der
situation zu haben
also wenn man jetzt momentan landkreise
sieht mit instanzen über 600 wir hatten
vor ein paar tagen ein gespräch mit
ihrer kollegin frau professor brinkmann
die sprach davon das ist eigentlich das
selbst 50 eigentlich noch nicht reicht
dass es unter 35 besser unter 25 runter
gehen müsste sehen sie das ähnlich
die zahl 50 hat man mal gewählt weil es
rein rechnerisch die kapazität der
gesundheitsämter ist wirklich dann auch
infektionsketten nachzuverfolgen und die
leute gezielt den quarantäne zu schicken
wenn das über 50 und deutlich über 50
hinaus geht dann ist das ganze einfach
außer kontrolle dann gibt es punktuell
ganz viele infektionen so wie wir es im
moment haben und man weiß eigentlich gar
nicht mehr so richtig wo es herkommt
deswegen wäre das mal so der erste ziel
wert den man erreichen will
aber das wäre es ist natürlich auch bei
der incident 52 nicht weg das muss man
sich klar machen ob dann 25 was bringt
das ist für jetzt logarithmisch
wachsende infektion kein sehr großer
unterschied aber wichtig wäre diesen
ersten schritt zu erreichen und zu sagen
okay
zumindest weiß man jetzt wieder wer wen
angesteckt hat und wie man gezielt auch
die herde wieder eindämmen kann
das wäre schon mal wirklich richtig ich
würde gerne noch kurz auf die schulen zu
sprechen kommen weil das natürlich auch
ein ganz normaler punkt ist auch für
viele familien wie geht es da weiter
wohl in den nächsten wochen was hat man
dafür erkenntnisse sind die schulen sind
die klassen pandemie treiber oder nicht
und was folgt daraus
nach dem was man bisher weiß wenn man so
versucht die literatur daten und auch
studien die hier in deutschland gemacht
wurden für sich selber zusammenzufassen
und das ist jetzt meine persönliche
interpretation
dann sind diese super sprayer ereignisse
die wir bei erwachsenen haben wollte
wieder ein mensch sehr sehr viele andere
ansteckt das ist zumindest bei kleineren
kindern scheint das selten zu sein
in den höheren klassen kommt das
natürlich vorher in der oberstufe in den
berufsschulen da ist das genauso wie bei
dem wie bei den erwachsenen auch aber
den unteren klassen scheint es doch eher
eine eins zu eins übertragung zu geben
wenn sie passiert und die kann man ja
ganz gut doch durch masken auch im griff
behalten
da wäre meine einschätzung bei den
unteren klassen kann man da sicherlich
ein bisschen früher mit dem unterricht
wieder anfangen zu tun sich auch härter
natürlich über online medien zu arbeiten
ich glaube die die älteren die können
das einfach schon besser sie die sind
das gewohnt mit ihrem handy umzusetzen
und sich dazu orientieren
also ich denke dass das so
entscheidungsgrundlagen am gegeben wären
aber wie das dann genau gemacht wird ist
natürlich letztendlich doch mit eine
politische entscheidung klar noch mal
eine medizinische sozusagen basis frage
von daniel mau über youtube ist man bei
immunität nach durchgemachter
infektionen noch ansteckend
nein da kann man glaube ich ganz klar
beantworten
man hat dann diese antikörper und man
hat diese neutralisierenden antikörper
im idealfall auch schön im
nasen-rachen-raum und dann kann man sich
niemals selber nicht mehr anstecken oder
man selber nicht angesteckt das kann
kann man auch keinen anderen mehr
anstecken
eine frage drängt sagen man weiß noch
nicht ganz genau wie lange diese
immunität erhält
wir selber haben eine große studie
gemacht mit 4500 teilnehmern und wir
sehen schon dass die immunität die
menschen in der ersten welle erworben
haben also im märz/april abgenommen hat
bis zum november also etwa 25 prozent
haben ihre immunität wieder verloren
und deswegen selbst wenn man es durch
gemacht hat weiß man halt nicht ganz
genau dass man wirklich noch immun oder
nicht malek fragt über youtube wie
findet man heraus wer nicht geimpft
werden darf sprich bei welchen
vorerkrankungen sollte man sich nicht
impfen lassen
ich nehme an da ist ein gespräch mit dem
hausarzt sinnvoll
absolut ich würde das immer mit dem
hausarzt beim vor besprechen
bisher gibt es keine erkrankung wo man
sagt da darf man sich gar nicht impfen
lassen
es sind diese beiden oder inzwischen ein
paar anaphylaktische reaktionen
beschrieben worden
das ist sehr sehr selten aber das wissen
wir das kommt eigentlich bei 1
impfstoffen vor das kommt auch bei
eigentlich allen medikamenten die man
irgendwo systemisch gibt vor dass es
solche anaphylaktischen also hoch
allergischen reaktionen gibt am darf
sind die impfzentren vorbereitet und
auch die impfärzte vorbereitet die
kennen das die haben dann schon
gegenmittel dabei das war bisher auch
immer sehr gut zu beherrschen bei allen
klappt sechs fällen die jetzt weltweit
aufgetreten sind
also insofern ist auch das keine
absolute kontraindikation aber man
sollte das natürlich trotzdem vorher
besprechen auch mit dem impf arzt
besprechen damit sie wissen worauf sie
sich einstellen können und dass dann
vielleicht auch die nachbeobachtungszeit
von den jetzt vorgeschriebenen 15
minuten so ein bisschen verlängert wird
was oft beklagt wird auch bei uns aber
auch generell auch in den medien viel
ist ja ja die frage nach einer
langfristigen strategie beziehungsweise
es wird bemängelt dass es diese
langfristige strategie eben nicht so
eindeutig gibt kann es die aus ihrer
sicht überhaupt geben oder müssen wir
immer auf sicht fahren das heißt immer
lockern
dann wieder den shutdown und dann wieder
lockern und den schatten oder wie sehen
sie das
also ich glaube was schon sehr
wünschenswert wäre wenn man eine
gemeinsame strategie hat auf die man
sich geeinigt also zum beispiel wenn man
sagt in dem moment in dem die inzidenz
werte über 50 ansteigen passiert abc das
kann ja lokal passieren aber es wäre
irgendwo eine klare grenze die auch alle
nachvollziehen können und dann in dem
moment in dem die inzidenz über 200
ansteigt dann muss ich einfach wirklich
dort wo das der fall ist auch
runterfahren und das heißt nicht dass
ich das immer ganz deutschland machen
muss aber es sollten doch sich
vielleicht mal alle versuchen auf
irgendwo einen fahrplan zu einigen dann
ist es tatsächlich für alle menschen
inklusive uns als fachleuten inzwischen
sehr verwirrend sich so anzuschauen was
in den unterschiedlichen bundesländern
einfach unterschiedlich passiert und im
idealfall würde man das nicht nur in
deutschland einheitlich machen sondern
in ganz europa einheitlich machen denn
wir haben ja viele menschen die über die
grenzen pendlern und so ein virus das
bleibt ja nicht irgendwie an der grenze
stehen sondern das betrifft ja auf jeden
fall uns gemeinsam mit unseren nachbarn
also wenn man sich da mal auf gemeinsame
strategie einigen könnte dann wäre schon
sehr viel gewonnen das heißt immer noch
dass man auf das infektionsgeschehen
natürlich reagieren muss aber man könnte
halt viel viel einheitlicher reagieren
es ist bei ihm geht schon das licht
ausgegangen wir nehmen das jetzt einfach
sprache als zeichen auch wenn es jetzt
wieder brennt frau professor ganz
herzlichen dank dass ihr uns heute abend
für dieses gespräch zur verfügung
gestanden haben einen guten
jahresausklang wünsche ich ihnen und ein
gesundes jahr 2021 vielen dank das
wünsche ich ihnen und ein zu hören auch
dankeschön und genau liebe user danke
auch dass er zugeschaut habt das war
voraussichtlich die letzte ausgabe in
diesem jahr des live streams auch an
euch natürlich kommt gut ins neue jahr
ein gesundes jahr 2021 und bis dann
hoffentlich ganz bald macht's gut